welcome to this video I am let x EV be
my opponent so am i getting checkmated
again in the dragon maybe I am I have a
new idea i will look later it just takes
it well i didn't even look at when i
studied this briefly yesterday okay p
takes five so i probably have to check
with this okay that is not very
ambitious but it's also not terribly bad
so how to play him I don't want to play
into cells pins yeah with stuff like
with stuff like an ID 7 p-6 bishop a
section I don't know where to put this
little bit difficult should be six so
not looking all that grade
and it's an interesting
ok so after this I don't expect long
castles to be dangerous film 97 life
beyond if he go with 85 and b5
maybe 95 here I don't know 95 is killing
my pawn structure really but when it's
probably still good well that isn't
really a problem to the bishop is so
strong then ok so here I have Bishop to
e6 I can also take on c3 it's an
interesting more strategically Bishop a
sex is also interesting yeah I like this
actually for night before next that is a
real nuisance on the sea to pawn the
night
isn't that they only move anyway okay we
should be too maybe he has but now a
tribe is interesting and an interesting
interesting position there is seven
forms week I don't know that could be an
issue really yeah a night this night
before is a good move to have but the a
seven point is extremely extremely weak
IAM and it's very difficult to give it
out wow ok that isn't good just isn't
good at all
hmm that wow that that time is played I
really did amazing so Bishop 86 was bad
it was bad not sure if I'm still okay
wow that doesn't just that good I mean I
have to push him back first and I should
get a five and I hope I'm okay
Wow
time running great great king of eight
Bishop c5 amazing stuff
I didn't see that at all ok so here I
can get this counter play them 36 and
maybe I should have done that
differently anyway
fix the pole and a 597 might still win I
cannot play that move great
I every hate to be in this position
after that harm is an opening where
delicious I mean that was just a
question black is better or equal but um
played badly afterwards really did and
it's also a crack move can just go a six
should check in immediately
[Music]
I didn't even see that things get better
and better here haha like resumes yeah
that's bad I mean this is such a lame
open anger and then I played it badly
relief someone I see fire fire black is
completely fine absolutely fine I mean
the Rick the only question is if I can
be better or not Bishop a 6n it really
didn't do much I mean this is just a
very strong piece there and not even
Bishop takes you three as an idea so
this was my original plan and this is a
lot more centralized and now i'm already
threatening to take then some cases and
give them a bad ending i have no
problems whatsoever and this son yeah
now probably yeah that is just not a
good move we should be fired immediately
okay yeah cause I mean here i was
playing on this idea here and I didn't
see Bishop c5 of course i was thinking i
go here he goes here look here back and
i'm ok i'm not even ok here because of
might be five which i didn't see that
before is ok though now but ok he has to
be a special c5 I mean it's kind of it's
just what it is he has this move and
then the death move is pointless king of
890 is just just better than to buy mile
now yeah that that's not defensible I
cannot defend this position that's just
too strong for wine yeah that I miss
played pretty badly am now I should have
played very bishop I will lost too
ambitious there and underestimated a
five I mean this seems to be ok but I
wasn't the intention and this is better
it's much more centralized also i mean
this this is not dangerous at all it's
not even threatening to win a poem when
I have denied him yeah add it off I just
said the most just badly ready played ok
thanks for watching